then you have you probably were thinking
anything well no so you have to look
like this you also have to look at
things too with how we do things you
know like Anderson bent is a perfect
example when how so how you know you
have your intention when you're writing
something and then there's an
interpretation side and then it's you
know how does this fit now or how you
know and then it's kind of like us
talking in or speaking in the abstract
with whatever we're approaching and
what's going to work what I think is
some of the interesting things about us
too and it's also not taking it's great
to have one your depth of experience and
my set of experience and then
collaboration on what we're doing with
things Jonah mean like how we cast
Anderson bench was on a certain path and
then it's when we started casting it we
shifted into a different direction that
was her fault was great um but that's
what I think that's what the tag-team
between us John I mean it's both of our
skill sets we only have to ask us right
and here's the thing we may be wrong
right the emai be wrong and people may
look at these movies and go no no thank
you but the cool thing is it's it's our
investment and I don't have anyone we
don't have anyone to make it up to we
don't have anyone to apologize to we
aren't so desperate to make the money
back because she's so smart at how at
how the money is spent we're not so
desperate to make the money back that
we're willing to compromise whatever we
feel is the right way to tell a story
the right way to cast a film the right
location to shoot a film in we don't
have that element which is oh my god
it's so freeing but we may be wrong but
if we're right and if we're wrong
doesn't matter what I'm tomorrow we'll
do another one
you